esta fotografía tomada el martes en la
ciudad de irving al norte de ucrania
muestra una lluvia de estelas blancas
que iluminan el cielo nocturno para el
alcalde de la ciudad esta sería la
prueba de que rusia habría utilizado
municiones de fósforo blanco en la
ciudad una acusación lanzada nuevamente
en esta ocasión por parte de volodymyr
taléns que
esta mañana hemos visto bombas de
fósforo bombas rusas de fósforo
las autoridades ucranianas aseguran que
están investigando el posible uso del
fósforo blanco por parte de rusia en
irvine pero también en la región del
donbass vídeos de aficionados tomados de
hace dos semanas parecen mostrar estelas
de luz' similares pero estas denuncias
no han sido verificadas de forma
independiente y moscú ha negado las
acusaciones
es un arma incendiaria el uso del
fósforo blanco contra ciudadanos está
prohibido por la convención de ginebra y
si se demuestra su uso sería un crimen
de guerra
el fósforo blanco arde a temperatura
extremadamente altas hasta 1300 grados
centígrados por supuesto puede provocar
incendios pero también causar quemaduras
extremadamente graves e incluso mortales
y es pues a pesar de ser un arma
condenada en el mundo el fósforo blanco
se ha utilizado en varios conflictos del
pasado